hi I'm Chad knutson I work with Wolfram
research hi my name is Lynne I also work
for Wolfram research hi my name is Arash
Matt Ian and I work for firm research as
well and the title of our talk is
developing applications for the Wolfram
enterprise private cloud some examples
tips and tricks sorry about the delay so
our presentation is going to be
discussing how we go about developing
applications for Wolfram enterprise
private cloud okay so first of all what
we mean by a modern web application so
well we expect our application to be
responsive right so it displays on
different screens do need bigger here
okay we're lost my mouse where you go
where the heck is the mouse it's in the
court sorry I'm totally blind here don't
have this help no I can't see well okay
I'm sorry about that i'll just keep
going unless you want to try to take
over for that so what do we mean by what
modern web applications so responsive
right so it displays correctly on
whatever screen you're looking at
whether it's a laptop tablet or a phone
we want it to be interactive so users
can do different things with it that
multiple functionality yeah we're
working on okay there we go and we'd
like to be fast right so and that's a
relative term but generally that means
that whatever evaluations that could be
done locally and the clients machine
will do there so generally that means
we're going to be using some JavaScript
so our approach is that we're going to
use some Wolfram research technology for
the server-side back end like what we
saw in the previous talk and then we'll
have some HTML CSS JavaScript that's
going to handle the front end for us
okay so our Wolfram technologies what do
we have will we have the Wolfram cloud
we have the Wolfram enterprise private
cloud we have some built-in functions
and Wolfram language that helped us to
deploy things so we have things like
cloud deploy form function form page API
function
it's some of these evaluations to being
incredibly complex right so we're going
to have the full capability of the
Wolfram colonel on the back end but
generally these built-in functions have
a single functionality right you provide
a data to a function you get something
out but yeah again they can be pretty
complex so let's see if I do this a
great there we go so this is just an
example of like what we could deploy a
form function that takes in a number and
the output of that can be a manipulate
so it's very interactive first of all
for the user input and then the user can
also click on this and initiative time
I'll skip over that so we can move on to
other examples okay so first example is
going to be a really trivial web example
that I've put together that uses some of
the tools i talked about JavaScript
styling and so forth and the
architecture of this is going to be
everything is going to deployed on the
cloud so the cloud is hosting our HTML
our javascript files styling and it's
also going to host the API functions so
if I click on the link to this hopefully
this will work we have an internet
connection oops it's loading that's kind
of a bad sign there's some
yeah throw at me okay wow this is going
to be really pretty difficult
oh can I think Jackie's okay let's see a
VPN we can live without for now yeah so
hopefully that's going to load up yeah
so for this case I'm deploying to the
public cloud so if we didn't have to
deal with any VPN issues but if we don't
have any network at all then the live
demonstration is not going to work I'll
give it a second it's not really
responding okay so yep power well
unfortunately just have to kind of talk
through about the kind of functionality
that we have implemented in there so
this this deployment we had a back end
where we deployed a couple of API
functions so the first function was to
take an input we're calling the math
expression interpreter on it so the user
is going to type in some sort of math
expression and they want to see a plot
of it so the output of that is going to
be in the JSON format so and we have
this key for the JSON and plot and we're
exporting the plot of the image in a
base64 format which is pretty useful for
the JavaScript to be able to read that
in and load it to the webpage the the
extension that we did to go kind of
beyond what we can do with just simple
woeful language is we have some error
handling on the input so and this is
handled with an event handler with
JavaScript so the user types in their
input and maybe they don't want to send
the full evaluation without knowing
exactly what they type in making sure
that it's correct so we have this API
function that just takes an input here
now instead of using the math expression
interpreter directly on the input I just
accept the string that they provided
into my API function then later I call
the interpreter function on a math
expression then I have this error
checking on that if that failed then I'm
going to return to the user that hey I
couldn't parse your input so won't you
try something else if it succeeds then
we're going to again create an image
that's going to be sent to JavaScript
it's how Wolfram language parsed it okay
and so the front end we have an HTML
page that I wrote and I won't go into
any many very many details about that so
this HTML page basically you know loads
the JavaScript style our job
script code that we need any styling
specifications are in there and this is
one way that I've found helpful for
deploying the HTML page which is
basically from Mathematica notebook on
my desktop I can copy it up to the cloud
you know if I'm connected to the cloud
so that file is the pointing to the path
on my machine of this HTML page I create
a cloud object and I put it in the path
on the cloud that I wanted to go to
evaluate the function copy file that
upload it to the cloud and then I can
set the permissions to whatever I want
in this case I'm sending them to public
I do exactly the same thing with the
JavaScript code and against sending it
to public sure yeah yeah I'll have more
to say about that later but yeah if you
have a specific question about that this
is in this is done by a Wolfram colonel
right this is in the cloud in this case
but it could be in a private cloud yeah
okay okay and actually let me curious if
we can actually see if this is working
again so here is my page will go back
just one more time see if it works okay
probably not sure
sure sure yeah yeah I mean like I said I
mean this is it certainly it's a moving
target as for what's in the double front
leg or something like Carlo is here so
there's things that exist now that I not
fully aware of and there's more things
that I mean the future that that are
going to be done so right now there's
things that we can't do an open language
that yeah that we can handle a
JavaScript or other tools but yeah but
so yeah it's available now okay so one a
couple of additional notes that I want
to discuss here that you know our
authentication so I set the permissions
to public for this demonstration that
hopefully move and show at some point
but we can require authentication of
users I said we have lots of different
functions built in for that so
permissions groups are useful so if we
have a list of users that we want to use
the function we could set it to
authenticated users and so on so the
issue there is though that when we have
our JavaScript call our API functions
then that authentication credentials
need to be sent along with their request
right and so that can be handled in the
JavaScript and then so more on this
error handling and there's again that's
Carla points that there's lots of
different ways to do that but i just
want to point out that the json format
is really nice with an interface between
Wolfram language and JavaScript all
right so we can take in input as
json.parse it and we can send out data
as JSON as well so the simple API
function this is actually done locally
so we're taking in JSON we have a string
that's just going to come out of this
and we parse our JSON using the lookup
function so in our input string that's
basically this is what is going to look
like you know if it's coming from an
HTTP request so we have the key first
name last name and age and if we
evaluate that what comes out is hello
Ricky Henderson you are 57 years old so
that's Parker ectly yet another way that
we can handle little errors again with
JSON is we can add in our output key
likes a success key and so that in our
front-end knows like okay I don't even
need to deal with whatever output has
come from the API because I know that
something is failed here so this is a
case where I'd you know check on the age
at the
is a negative number then my success
keys set to failure you can see that
here if I evaluate it so if i gave it
Ricky Henderson's input he's still 57 if
I say that I'm minus 3.5 years old the
success key is failure that can help our
JavaScript aps yes if you're getting
outputs is Jason that tends to mean that
it's a list right but we probably have
to look at your example but yeah if it's
square bracket that means a list in JSON
notation so there's a default parameter
can't remember exactly what it's called
I think it's dollar permissions so you
can set that to be whatever you want it
to be and that will automatically go to
that but yes some of these functions
don't have the option like copy file
doesn't have yet an option for setting
the permissions of the cloud object sure
sure yeah that would be a safe way to do
I think it's dollar sign permissions
that correct yeah okay all right so me
all right thank you so basically we're
sorry for the
be basically we don't have any internet
connection so I'll just pretend that we
have shown the demo but the basic idea
is basically you have everything the
whole back end will be provided by the
Wolfram Enterprise private cloud in the
sense that it hosts it not only provides
the functionality but it also is a
hosting solution however in a lot of
real world scenarios you either have
some existing system in which case
Wolfram language and the private cloud
is just part of the picture that you
need to integrate into your ecosystem or
that you would like to have a final
control over how users go about
accessing your web applications so with
that in mind I want to show you another
example which uses a which is also very
simple but uses a slightly different
architecture so as the diagram shows
here what we have is we add in a middle
layer in between the client view and the
micro services provided by the
enterprise private cloud so this middle
layer would usually be a additional web
server so in our case we use Tomcat but
of course you can use any other servers
of your choice so with this setup we can
delegate a lot of ops related tasks for
example user authentication site hosting
logging caching even load balancing we
can put all those tasks on to the middle
layer and then the Wolfram private cloud
would just become a we just act solely
as a feature provider mostly in the form
of API calls or say my micro services so
i'm going to have a mock up version of
the example i'm going to show so even
though we don't have connection to the
cloud and even though we are saying when
you were showing an example that works
with the cloud we're not really but
at least we'll get give you some ideas
so corresponding back to the diagram I
talked about so these basically the
client view is just written in HTML and
JavaScript so specifically we use react
a real library open source by Facebook
and then as I mentioned previously the
middle layer here is just the Tomcat
which we use for user authentication and
site hosting and then lastly the Wolfram
back end the private cloud provides the
API calls so that we can do data
management as well as some time series
analysis which hopefully a rush will be
able to talk about in a bit so let's
pretend we'll do some kind of login
anything will work so again this is just
a mock-up version of the real app so the
first part of the application is like a
dashboard view even though it's simple
it does exemplify a common data flow in
the sense that you will use the Wolfram
cloud api's to constantly pulling in
data and then those data will get
rendered by the client view and also
your middle layer because it all the API
costs will be proxied by this middle
layer which means that once you lose the
authentication you won't be able to make
any further API calls right so let me
pretend to re-login back and then I will
hand this over to a rush because the
second part of the application is doing
some data query and the data query how
they have a lifting is managed by the
Wolfram cloud
[Music]
so hello can you so basically this what
I'm going to talk about is the back end
considerations for your private cloud
application like what what what tips and
tricks you can use in the back end
development that would basically
facilitate your process in the in your
application and so before I go back to
the notebook I just want to show like
what what exactly i mean so like one of
the options is that basically you you
have some data sets and databases that
you tap into while you're showing data
to the customer and so this is one
example of having a database of sales in
in different states and down so
basically like right now we have like
five columns that we've amassed rating
in our table that the quantity of the
product that is sold the part number
description where it's all the state
code and the product line so basically
this is just a simple like it's kind of
a select statement on the database if
you're familiar with the database
language that you can basically be
construct these pull downs based on the
values that are in the database and then
select probably one of the columns and
then so because of the richness of war
from language you can basically
construct a lot of reporting on the fly
quickly using that data so years for
example when I get the results I get
some descriptive statistics of that
column very quickly time series of that
and also the forecast of it like I can
forecast for the last two weeks it's
probably very small here and then also
the histogram of that the sale in and
throughout the history or
I can basically look at the two two
columns together this case I choose a
like another category called basically
this with a continuous variable and
another categorical variable and then it
basically constructs like a tabulation
of that table in addition to
automatically understands that basically
you have a continuous variable versus a
categorical variable and does an ANOVA
analysis to see if there is a
significant difference between product
numbers sales and you can see there is a
significant difference and and also
shows you again the histogram or you can
choose to like continuous variables and
then the ganic understands that because
you have two continuous variables what
analysis makes sense and then it does
basically some correlation and like a 2d
3d histogram on that so with that I go
back to notebook so and then this was a
basically notebook on the cloud that I
can't show unfortunately but what I had
listed there basically the options that
you can store your data obviously one is
the database the the sequel database
available on the private cloud and and
the other option is basically if there
are some data that are not necessarily
easy to fit into the database you can
save them as MX files and then the other
thing is that like so all the packages
you have is also one option is to put
them into your MSP configuration once
the tomcat comes up basically your your
package is available and can be used and
I had some examples to show how you can
basically use those distant by the way
this notebook is available on the path
also you it's available to download and
you can't look at the examples just very
quickly i mentioned to a very useful
functions cloud account data that
basically shows you
some basically settings that are and the
cloud which are basically the three
categories are here is basically the if
you if you look at it there is memory
limit and also time limit and the these
two are scattered like for session
deployed and scheduled task and these
are basically the things that it's it's
it's good to know and to manipulate
because they're there they could be by
default like they're set in minimum
level because you're basically colonel
doesn't get hugged by some requests but
in some cases you might need some more
memory or some more time to do some
calculations that is required to be
changed here and then finally cloud
logging data also is very useful to
basically find out like you have
different api's deployed and forms and
scheduled tasks it basically collects
all the logs and in different time
periods so by default for example gives
you the last day last week or last month
and all of the forms computations you
had for example here I'm looking at just
the task is you'll task for the for this
year 2016 and I can show see quickly
like how it has changed during the last
few months that I think I just open up
to questions if there is